uh welcome everybody to the second day
of the workshop and I'm very happy to
have the best week open the session with
this talk on from Big Data to systems
pharmacology
thanks for the invitation very nice it's
actually my first time at this side of
the day
now like it I'm a bit ashamed because
Pascal just told me that my title is
boring but
I'll try to make it more exciting
so basically I will start by saying that
these last years what I'm doing is
trying to overcome uh personal
frustration right so these are these are
my friends from childhood and as you can
see all of them are working in companies
that have to do with the image
processing and actual language
processing artificial intelligence Etc
so we're turning 50 this year which
means that we've been around for long
enough so that we we have witnessed all
the progress in this field for many many
years and in fact my first paper ever
was a neural network
in a journal that it was called cabaya
that's Computer Applications in
biosciences that this was the seat of
bioinformatics now right and as you can
see it was implemented in Excel
you can imagine that I didn't write a
neural network in Excel I implemented it
in C but then the comment that I got
back from the reviewers like if you want
any biologists to use a neural network
you have to be or it has to be
implemented in Excel because no
biologists will ever use a compiled
program so I did implement it
anyway so for the last 30 years or so I
wanted to play with my friends saying
hey guys I want to use your algorithms
these things so cool that you're doing
here and their answer was always the
same so you do not have enough data you
think you have a lot of data but you
don't have enough data to play with us
okay now screw them because we have more
data than they do right so now the
problem in biology and chemistry is not
the data anymore it's how we format this
data and this is what we're trying to do
in the lab for the last years
so let's start with chemistry first so
still small molecules are the main
assets of pharmaceutical companies as
you know
and basically This is Where I Come From
right bioinformatics many of you
proteins that's very cool so biology is
self-formatted we don't have to play
very much with it so if you're playing
with nucleic acid it's only four letters
if we're playing for protein this 20
amino acids we have this beautiful
domain architectures we have a sort of
clear sequence to structure to function
relationship and all these things have
been optimized by millions of years of
evolution and if anything we only have
around 20 000 proteins or 20 000 genes
one hundred thousand proteins that are
organizing beautiful databases when you
go to chemistry
there's a big mess right so this really
is help so these guys are monolithic
entities you cannot split them into
functional domains
nuclear architecture they have been if
anything mildly optimized by one medchem
a couple of rounds and we have more than
200 million commercially available
molecules you can pick up the phone by
one of these but the the chemical space
is huge and we're talking about 200
billion molecules that could be easily
synthesizable here
so and if anything you can look at this
you might not know this RNA Paul too but
it's pretty clear that there's a
template there's a machine and there's
something that is being copied you look
at this and you either know exactly what
it does or you cannot guess its function
so what the the computational chemists
have been doing in the last 30 40 years
is trying to encode somehow the chemical
structure of this compound so that we
can compare them right so trying to
encode this information in the form of a
vector different types 2D 3DS uh
scaffolds Etc because what we know is
that whenever two molecules look similar
they tend to bind to the same receptors
have sort of the same
targets
then in the last years thanks to this
all the Islamic techniques that we all
love what we have seen is that not only
molecules with similar structures tend
to bind the semi-receptors but molecules
with similar transcriptional profiles
tend to have similar bioactivities or
the molecules that kill the same sort of
cancer cell lines also tend to have
similar bioactivities so what we set up
to do with Miguel Duran in my lab some
six years ago already is trying to
encode in the form of a vector not the
not the the chemical structure of these
compounds but their bioactivities
right and this is exactly what we did in
a resource that we call the chemical
checker for obvious reasons that
basically is formed by information for
one million more than one million
bioactive molecules for which we have
experimental information so no
bioinformatics Matrix here yet right and
then what we did is to organize this
resource in five levels of complexity
following a little bit the rationale of
how we understand drug action right so
in the first level we have the chemistry
descriptors to the 3D fingerprints and
scaffold feature then for a molecule to
be bioactive it has to bind to a
biomolecule
this is the second level the target
mechanism of actions the genes that
metabolize these are small molecule
binding Etc then when you modulate the
activity of one of these Targets this
information gets kind of spread out in
the cell through networks of different
type signaling networks interactive
networks Etc and we can capture all this
information
in cell based experiments
gene expression cancer cell line panel
chemical genetics
high content screens Etc and finally for
the few molecules that reach the clinics
we also have this final layer of
information about therapeutic areas
indications
Etc
so big numbers are great but they are
difficult to interpret right and this
already goes into one discussion that we
were having with uh with Pascal and
Brenda yesterday so I guess you're
familiar with this resource so this is
the links 1000 from the broad Institute
so these guys have tested something like
20
000 different drugs between in 3 and 77
different cell lines three different
concentrations three different
checkpoints Etc so this is great but I
mean if we want to condense all this
information in the form of one single
Vector Associated to a small molecule
there's a lot of decisions that we have
to do here and one of them is trying to
disentangle what's the effect that is
due to the genetic background of the
cell and what's the real effect that is
the small molecule that is eliciting it
we have other examples drug response 15
different drugs experiments done in the
broad experiments than in the Sanger no
correlation only for one of the trucks
right so first conclusion is this thing
doesn't work well okay when you massage
the data properly it does work and
they're very clear correlations right
and this is an example very clear
paper that came up from perish Pascal
and co-workers we have two interact with
networks you compare them for things
like okay they don't overlap so they're
both wrong no you have to take into
account many different aspects like the
space that has been assayed the assay
sensitivity Etc and again when you take
all this into account then it works and
we have decent overlaps
so to get along with story short we kind
of massage all this data to create this
bioactivity descriptors and this slide
trauma is these three years of work in
my laboratory and I'm not even going to
talk about it
but again to cut a long story short what
we have now is 25 different bioactivity
descriptors to describe the
bioactivities of these small molecules
that tell us about
the chemistry itself the targets the
networks cell based database and the
clinical information
and they're complementary yes so how do
they look at these numbers or what are
they what these are vectors yes I'm
sorry this is what you see here in the
coordinates so it's it's 128 Dimension
vectors and they're continuous vectors
so for for each one of the bioactivity
spaces so this is what I'm showing here
so each each row is a drug and what you
see here is one of these descriptors for
each drug in one of the spaces chemistry
space mechanism of action in space
interacting space numbers they're real
numbers yes yes so they're just they're
vectors is what they are format all this
into a vector of real numbers
yeah use a certain Dimension was 25 or
120 it was 128 so we have we have 25
different bioactivity spaces and then
the vectors you need to once all the
descriptors in each one of these spaces
128 dimensions
story so it very much depends on the
space so if we're dealing with gene
expression so the the initial vectors
that we're dealing with is 18 000
because it's for all the teams if we are
dealing with physical chemical
properties we only have something like
18 dimensions right so we are kind of
compensating everything I mean trying to
keep as much variance as we can Etc and
at the end I mean lots of uh tests and
128 was a good that would work basically
yeah what do you do with the missing
information what do we do with the
missing information there's a lot of
missing information so it remains like
uh
offer for this there's no missing
information this is uh I'm sorry guys I
mean I just skipped it I mean this this
really goes into one uh kind of abstract
representation right so there might be
missing information in here so this is
the raw data but then at some point when
we go from what we've all seen into one
to see network two what we're building
here is similarity networks and then
we're using node to back so this is NLP
so there's there's no empty spaces in
here yeah
foreign
to show you that some of these
descriptors are fully complementary
right that's one example these trucks
that are using Ophthalmology whatever so
you can see that there's barely no
similarity in the chemical spaces but
then there's very clear structure of
both with respect to mechanism of action
and in fact
these are cool idea is it worth anything
so the best we can do is to compare it
to things that we know right so in this
case it's mechanism of action and
therapeutic areas for instance
and again you can see that in general
for all the spaces molecules that have
similar descriptors that will have
similar
mechanism of action and belong to
similar therapeutic areas right so there
is some information that we're clearly
retaining here
so as I said so we're developing this
from experimental information for one
million molecules right but we don't
have complete information for all these
molecules so this is what happens here
so we always have chemical information
we most of the times we have information
about targets we barely have any
information about clinical symmetries
so we have done is try to infer the
missing signatures for this one million
molecules right so imagine for compound
a we always have the chemistry and we
have some sparse signatures so we can
complete using Siamese networks all the
missing signatures and then of course we
can attach a kind of reliability a score
to each one of these inferences is not
really a relative reliability is
something that we call domain
applicability right
and now now we do have a complete set of
25 by activity descriptors for each one
of these 1 million molecules and this is
already enough
to build deep networks that go directly
from the chemical structure to the
prediction to the inference of this
bioactivity signatures right and this
allows us to go wild and to predict this
biotivity descriptors for any molecule
of Interest this is just one example
we're doing it for drugs for human
metabolites bacterial metabolites
compounds in plant extracts or compounds
in food
does it have any value it does right so
this is just one example so this is how
drugs for which we know the mechanism of
action cluster in the space if you only
consider their chemical structure and
this is how they cluster if you consider
their bioactivity signatures
so when user is here so we're comparing
it to the targets mechanism of action
therapeutic indications or diseases so
whenever you see blue in here it means
that the bioactivity signatures can
produce more coherent clusters whenever
you see red it means that is the
chemistry that works better right so you
can see that there is really an added
value in using this by activity
descriptors
and of course we can use this go wild
again and start playing with machine
learning Etc this is just a few
benchmarks of different complexity
clinical toxicology side effects just
penetration of the blood-brain barrier
Etc and then in general you can see that
whenever we use bioactivity descriptors
we get better performances that when we
only use chemical information not always
the more complex the task clinical
toxicology the better we are the simpler
the task like binding meet the secret
days or the protease of the HIV we get
similar performances than using just
chemical information
small molecules how about biology this
is a slight especially For You Pascal so
I defended my PhD in year 2000 right
after the first draft of the human
genome came out right then I started my
postdoc and I was very happy because
this was in the early 2000 and we had
the first genomes the first
transcriptones proteins interactions
people here in the audience and it was a
lot of data but we could cope with it
right we heard talks yesterday about
time and space transcriptomics right so
we have in different environmental
conditions extra levels of Regulation
personalized genome so we just we cannot
cope with all this data anymore I don't
my brain cannot cope with it right so
we're talking about more than 200
petabytes of data stored at DBI in more
than 1700 databases so we need a machine
to interpret this for us not always to
understand it but at least to try to
make some sense out of it
and since we were happy with the results
of the chemical checker for small
molecules we are trying or we try to do
something similar but coming up with
specific descriptors for biological
entities right so the first thing that
we did was to collect these gigantic
knowledge base graph that contains
information extracted from more than 150
different databases around 12 different
biological entities
Gene cells tissues diseases compounds
Etc
67 different associations so a gene is
dysregulated in a certain cell or is
mutated in a tissue or is related to a
disease and overall we have more than 30
million ages in here
and what we can do I mean we build this
gigantic Knowledge Graph we can explore
it using random workers right and then
off I mean involving any type of
relationship among these 12 different
biological entities that we want and
then again we go and play with NLP uh
uh algorithms right so that we can
transform these Corpus of random walks
into vectors right and at the end of the
day what we have is over 1 000 different
descriptors Associated to each one of
these 12 biological entities that are
context dependent right so classical one
so you have your favorite protein and
you can encode it using the amino acid
sequence but now this descriptor can be
different depending on whether you're
interested in the sequence you're
interested in the interactions that this
protein is associated with or the
transcriptional changes or whether is a
target for a given disease Etc so we can
describe these different biological
entities according to 1000 different
context dependent ways
and what next we have vectors chemistry
vectors biology you can merge everything
and this is what we're doing we're
working towards what we call a general
connectivity where the idea is that we
have our favorite biological signatures
of interest that either come from the
biotech or data that you are generating
in your lab and we have bioactivity
signatures for small molecules right so
we can start making matches and looking
for small molecules that are able to
match a given signature or to revert
this signature
examples this one is related to
Alzheimer's disease so as you can
imagine most of the data that populated
both the biotech and the chemical
Checker comes from cancer cell line
panels right so we wanted to see whether
we could extract some information
outside this rail so what we did in the
lab is to use this sh as Wi-Fi by cells
that are kind of neuron like and then we
introduce some mutations that are
related to Alzheimer's disease so we
engineered these cells in the lab right
so the chemical check or anything has
never seen these cells
and then basically we run some
differential gene expression experiments
wild-type cells mutated cells and then
we look for compounds in the chemical
Checker that we're able to revert these
differential gene expression signatures
right so look for compounds that are
able to move back the six cells into
healthy cells
okay this is just to show that the the
this engineer itself really work as they
are expected so changing the ratio
between maybe 40 to ab40 Etc
and these are the results so we did find
indeed three compounds and characterized
compound to approve drugs that are able
to revert this uh transcriptional
signature related to Alzheimer's disease
so we see here so we are pushing up the
genes that are down regulated in
Alzheimer's neuron like cells and we're
down regulating the ones that are up
regulated and this is not just random
genes right so we're hitting the genes
that are really related to Alzheimer's
disease so this guy in here is involved
in vesicle uh
endocytosis this one here the glutamate
receptor the synaptic membranes Etc
not for all of them but we're able to
revert something like
35 to 50 of these teeth
cell based assays how about being Vivo
so what we did in here we were playing
with three different Mouse models
related to Alzheimer's disease to
napkins one transgenic we took the
hypocampi of this mice and then we run
full transcriptomics and proteomics
experiments
we played a little bit with the standard
bioinformatics we identified modules and
then what we saw is that there were some
modules both at the transcriptional and
at the proteomics level that remained
very stable as the disease was
progressing but was firing up sorry as
in healthy aging right so these are mice
three six nine month old but they're not
healthy but they were firing up in the
Alzheimer mice right so here we played
exactly the same game so can we find any
drug that is able to revert this
transcriptional or proteomics module and
as you can imagine
because it's there was a way too complex
for for all the genes and there was a
lot of a terror 1080. so we we looked so
in the first case it was very well
controlled experiment it was exactly the
same neuron with a couple of mutations
now here we're talking about the whole
lipocampi right so so we really had to
do this this previous step first
so and then again the other thing is
that we're playing mice here not cells
which means that we cannot just feed
them with any compound that we want so
it has to be approved drugs or something
like that right so this is the game that
we played and then after so basically
using the chemical Checker from the the
initial 1 million compounds with the
trucks we ended up with 80 and that we
saw that belonged to mainly two
different groups right the non-steroid
the lung inflammatory drugs and
antihypertensive
so we selected six of them that had
never been related or tested for
Alzheimer's disease and to cut a long
story short we treat the Sig mice for a
month and then we run some Behavior
experiments right in this case it was a
novel object recognition so I don't know
whether you're familiar with it but you
just put a mice in a in a cage with with
one object so the mice get familiar then
you've replaced the object or put
another one and then the healthy mice
recognize that there's another object a
new one and it's curious and spends more
time exploring that one the Alzheimer's
markets don't remember and spend the
same time exploring the old and the new
this is what you see in here right so
the healthy mice spend 60 of the time
exploring the new object the sigmas
spend 50 of the time on each aux object
so four out of the six compounds that we
tested were indeed able to revert this
behavior and then when we went to the
molecular signatures we saw that indeed
we are reverting the gene expression
patterns we didn't check the proteomics
but we were reverting between expression
patterns in these mice three of the four
compounds were kind of pushing down the
overexpressed genes but there was only
one that is the one that worked best in
Behavior experiments as well that were
able to lift the down regulated genes in
the the mouse model
state
above
it so you want you want to get back to
normal
we want so the teams the genes that are
up regulated in Alzheimer's with respect
to the healthy might we want to put them
down to at the same level and the ones
that are done regularly you don't
understand you can see that we never
achieved a total effect right so this is
the expression so we can able to push
them down a little bit never to the to
the real basal state right in some cases
we are but not in hours but in any case
this seems to be enough at least to see
an effect from the phenotypic level
this is just I don't know what I have
time here so this is just another
example simpler one probably so what we
wanted to do here is to mimic one uh one
signature so you know that the
fire trucks are very trendy and very
powerful right so so monoclonal
antibodies Etc but they're expensive to
produce difficult to handle so our
rationale here is like if we can find a
small molecule that does the same job
than a monoclonal antibody this might
have some value right so this is just
one example we tested several so this is
we're trying to mimic the activity of
the clizu map so this is an antibody
that is induced to avoid rejection upon
organ transplantation right and what it
does is it binds to the interleuking
receptor and in the voice the signaling
down
right and it was personally discovered
using
pmbc cells
so what we did in this case is like Okay
so let's kill genetically the il2
receptor then again we run these
differential gene expression experiment
so cells healthy cells and cells with
the the knockdown uh
il-2 receptor but in this case we're not
only interested in the transcription we
don't care about the specific Target so
we want anything that will achieve the
same network effect globally right and
then we look for compounds that we're
able to mimic
the signature of the knockdown the
genetically knocked down il2 receptor
to cut a long story short we came up
with 19 compounds and 14 out of them we
were really able to prevent
proliferation depending on il-2
this is just one experiment and one cool
example of the power of this network
approach applied to to the bioactivity
signatures so this is for compound 20
uncharacterized compounds this is what's
happened with the cells that do not have
interleukin too so there is no
proliferation right
so we are interleuking too but no truck
and then cells start proliferating
we had the antibody and then the cells
stop proliferating when we had this
compound 20 we are able to stop
proliferation in a very nice
dose-dependent manner but we know that
Downstream of interleuking to receptor
is stat5 that gets phosphorylated and
then this is what we see here right so
we see phosphorylation when there's
interleukin tube but no drug when we add
the antibody phosphorylation stops when
we have this compound
phosphorylation of stat 5 is unaltered
so whatever it is that we are doing that
this compound 20 is doing is achieving
the same effect that is avoiding
proliferation depending on interleuking
2 but is not affecting
directly the il2 receptor or what is
immediately Downstream of it
this is kind this is why we call it a
systemic approach right so we're
achieving the same effect but touching a
different Target
find this is just to show that this is
not a nuclear bomb so we are we're
avoiding proliferation depending on what
you're looking to only
foreign
slide so I think despite the boring
title Pascal I think that I've showed
you that we have created this chemical
Checker that is a repository that
contains experimental
bioactivity information for about 1
million molecules and then we have
developed this bioactivity signatures or
fingerprints that we can use to extend
the similarity principles to different
levels of biology fine then using all
these we have developable we call this
signaturizer that is now that we can
infer this bioactivity signatures for
any compound of interest and we're
merging it with this biological
descriptors that we engulf in what we
call the biotech and all together we can
start playing this much revert thing
between biological descriptors and small
molecule descriptors in this kind of
General connectivity I showed you a
couple of examples Alzheimer's disease
the clinical map we have a few more that
are published and some others that are
coming
and if anything I always think that this
is kind of this parable of the Indian
blind man and the Elephant right so I
guess you're familiar with it but
basically it's these five six Indian
blind man that get into the jungle and
then they bump into an elephant so this
guy in here they're playing a force to
say look I found a rope say no what do
you mean a rope is a wall I cannot pass
you know it's a tree because I can hold
a trunk right and then the idea here is
that they all have partial information
so if instead of using only one type of
descriptor for small molecules or for
biological entities we can combine
different types of complementary
descriptors maybe we can have have a
global picture of what small molecules
or the different uh genes Etc will do
and this is the most important slide
this is my group close to my place and
basically most of the work that I
presented was done by Mikhail Duran in
collaboration with uh Edward Powells and
some technicians in the lab and thank
you very much and we'll be happy to take
questions
[Applause]
my way so how about side effect and
after the kind of unforeseen you know
I mean it very much depends on the type
of descriptor that you that you use to
mimic or to deliver these effects
if you go for mechanism of action or
Target in principle you should be
mimicking
music exactly if you go for something
more Global Anything could happen then
of course what we can do and we are
doing we start playing with combinations
of the script you're saying okay so I
want a molecule that reverts or mimics
this effect but are not close to these
other molecules that I know are causing
trouble
user
to your what means doing exactly yes is
a different criteria so in terms in
terms of our descriptors what it means
is finding molecules that have closed
the scriptures to the things that we
want but uh but this the combination of
these different bioactivity spaces
becomes uh by the user in the case of
Alzheimer's in the cells we only use
transcriptional data we demise we use
transcription and protonomics with the
Cleveland map we use transcriptional
proteomics and networks
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
is in your chemical Checker you have
economic funds if you go to the previous
line you have one
one
next slide like the conclusion slide so
you have one million compounds and then
you get their signatures in like these
vectors
do you also provide the raw data out of
which you made these vectors okay only
carbon health so it's it's nice we
cannot do it so what we have I mean I'm
sorry I didn't go to Techie here but we
have different types of signatures right
so the first signature is what we call
Signature zero that this is just a very
easy preprocessing of the world data but
you don't provide we don't provide these
no the raw data we can knock we don't
want and we cannot you can we don't want
because we have to credit the people
that is maintaining the primary
databases and these experiments right
and the second one is that some of these
data comes from databases that are
protected right so it's like everything
is public for academics but not
everything is public for industry for
instance and then you can always provide
the transform data our signatures but
you cannot reproduce the raw data but if
you use the signature zero this should
be very very similar because this is
just a big Matrix we're not condensing
anything into vectors or anything yet so
it's just a big Matrix and all these
compounds all the features in the case
of gene expression the the 18 000
different vectors is a yes or no or is a
continuous value so our signature zero
that are in the chemical sector and the
biotech you can download these these
slides but but the raw data precisely
we're not providing because we don't
want to plan because
so this thing to do it with the
Alzheimer's
so there are thousands of differentially
expressed data sets comparing this is
this versus normal so you could do it
automatically for all of them right so
we cannot test them experimentally and
then the value is going to be prelimited
so we're doing many in some cases in
collaborations uh with other people for
instance with Antonio Garcia Guerreros
in the ubf we're playing with Inhibitors
and indirect limiters of snail one to
avoid the the
the cancer metastasis for instance but
the value begins to be able to validate
something experimentally and my white
lab is pretty smooth so we cannot do we
cannot do everything
and for the bioinformatics As I said
we're providing everything I mean the
code and all the and all the signatures
uh for free so you guys can go play it
and do it with your favorite pieces
so I'm it's it's beautiful I really love
this stuff I'm not familiar enough with
the signatures obviously
um but when you when you go into your
your biological signatures that you that
you briefly mentioned
um and look at those four kind of
complex autoimmune disease right we're
very good genetics there
um can you use those on the one hand to
identify new
predisposing genes but then also for the
ones that you already have say okay this
one's probably working 18 cells this
other one is probably affecting the
function of epithelial cells and kind of
better use the signatures and and the
combination the fusion of all this
knowledge to better understand the
disease mechanisms that underline this
yes or no so we are doing that and it's
coming out in the paper and part of it
is multiplier either way so what we can
do is use different descriptors right so
these 1000 descriptors and then we can
see which ones are the ones that the
better much the disease signatures that
we have experimental right and then this
will give you an idea of saying look if
we see that the the descriptor that
contain protein protein interaction uh
information are not relevant at all then
probably we cannot explain this using
the protein interactions or the
transcription is very important then
this gives you some hints right what we
cannot do is directly relate this very
abstract descriptors to the genes that
are bringing the information this
weekend but what we can do is predict
type of thing okay so we see that for
this phenomena are these descriptors are
the most relevant and then we can go and
predict new biological entities for
instance
Etc that have similar features and then
some of these not experimentally but
some of these have been validated in
this kind of a Time series right so
we're using data that was not using here
and then we made predictions and then in
a couple of a month or two years is
there's information that comes out and
in some cases the lower right
so you can use it to understand to get
some hints of where the signal comes
from and to make prediction but not to
trace down exactly to a deal or to an
interaction that is going to be key for
this disease so no mechanistic is
unfortunately okay I guess
[Applause]
next
speakers
you have to be this title here